So in addition to conformity, another way in which people influence us is
authority figures can sometimes get us to do what we may not even want to do.
That is, obedience to authority. Now, in fact one of the most famous studies in
all of psychology was on that topic, obedience to authority. And it was carried
out in the 1960s. By the Yale University psychologist Stanley Milgram. And
Milgram was driven to understand and ask the question. How is it that Germans
can send so many innocent people to their deaths? Because the standard answer
at the time was, well we were just following orders. So Milgram wanted to
understand whether authority and obedience to authority could explain such a
tragic event. So what do you think? Do you think obedience to authority could
lead people to hurt or even kill people?